hey guys if you haven't been playing
along on Twitter or Facebook I am
actually in Israel right now I'm on the
beach in Tel Aviv this is the
Mediterranean Sea behind me it's about
six-thirty a.m. on thursday november
december third there was this mass
shooting in San Bernardino California
last night which I've been trying to
stay off social media a little bit while
I've been here and focused I was doing a
video conference I gave a speech at a
video conference thing and I've been
I've been trying to meet with people and
talk about peace i'm going to do an
interview today that I think you guys
are gonna find really interesting anyway
I saw this thing last night and then
basically just couldn't sleep all night
so it's super early here I just wanted
to make a video on this thing real quick
yeah this is this is terrible I I can't
tell you how bizarre it feels to be
halfway across the world especially here
in Israel where they deal with this kind
of thing all the time at different
levels and that it's that there was a
massive shooting not that far away from
Los Angeles where I live I thought the
reaction of course on social media was
all the usual nonsense you know what I
mean there was almost dislike glee at
the beginning from the usual suspects
when they thought it was gonna be a
white guy that did it or white people
that did it or Christian terrorists of
people were blaming the Republicans and
the NRA and all that and of course I
never defend the Republicans or the NRA
and then slowly it came out it sounds
like this guy has that he might be
Pakistani or something I don't know or
now his father I guess is saying that he
is a religious Muslim I don't know it's
early in all this but I I guess I wanted
to make a video just to say something
which is we got to be unafraid to call
out evil [ __ ] no matter which quarter it
comes from so whether this guy had been
a Christian fundamentalist or Muslim
fundamentalist or a Jewish
fundamentalist or Scientologist might
fundamentalist or [ __ ] you know Star
Wars fundamentalist but well that guy
would have been pretty good but the
point is we have to not be afraid to
call
[ __ ] out you cannot there is no excuse
you cannot kill innocent people no
matter what your problem is no matter
how begrudged you feel no matter how
whatever you think has been done to you
the second wheel how that the second we
excuse it if all bets are off than
anyone can do anything for any reason
that's it it really is that simple if we
want society we want this world that's
getting smaller because the technology
like this if we want this world to be
better then that [ __ ] cannot happen and
that does not excuse state violence
either I don't know how many times I
have to say it for these regressive
morons anyway it's weird we're in a
small world these days and we'll find
out more and and we'll see what happens
but I'll be here for a couple more days
so keep playing along on social media
and you can find out what I'm up to and
as always I thank you guys for your
support and digging what I do